you can't save yourselves but you can  save your legacy  you can't be here  you know that i can't be the first one  who wanted to see  my youngest self  strange watching yourself being born  a genetic dynasty has reigned for almost  four centuries  the might of the imperium  has brought peace to thousands of worlds  but the beliefs of one man  [Music]  now threaten the empire's very existence  i'm not a revolutionary calculations  are correct the empire is dying  order will vanish wars will be endless  only we can shorten the darkness  the man has a master following people  who  hinge their hopes on every words held in  others  words have a way of fanning into  wildfires  you can't save yourselves  but you can't save your legacy  [Music]  you